- What's up? My name is Edem Atsu-Swanzy.
- My name is Evan Benham.
- My name is Josell Mariano.
- [All] And I'm a male model.
(light, upbeat music)
- So I love style and fashion.
I just don't like paying a lot for it.
These guys are in style and fashion
and they get paid for it.
It's their job, they're experts.
I want to know, can they
really tell the difference
between cheap and expensive clothing?
Let's find out.
(energetic music)
- [Interviewer] How confident
do you feel that you
would be able to spot, you know,
cheap versus expensive men's clothing?
- That's a no brainer.
I could spot that from like, a mile away.
- I try on clothes for a living.
I wear expensive clothes everyday.
My boxers probably cost
more than your outfit.
- Now I like to wear nicer
things that fit really well.
Made out of really great material,
and I think I can tell the difference
between the cheap stuff and
the more expensive stuff,
so I'm pretty confident.
(energetic music)
- First test, you've got
these cards right here.
Boom. One, two, and three,
from cheapest to most expensive.
You guys together,
collectively, need to figure out
which one is which.
I want to see if you guys are right.
See if you actually know
what you're talking about.
Let's bring in the guys.
Come on in, fellas.
Okay.
So here we go.
- [Interviewer] The rules are no touching.
Let's see what you guys have got.
- Right off the bat I'm thinking
that one is the most expensive.
- [Evan] That leather,
that leather just looks
- Like genuine leather to me.
- Yeah.
- It's really gleaming.
- Yeah and all the gleaming.
- I like him, you know what I'm saying?
- Yeah.
- Exactly.
I see that.
- The details there,
zippers and all that stuff.
- The brown one.
It doesn't even look like real brown.
- That's what I'm saying.
- (laughing)
What is that made from?
You know what I mean?
- That's what I'm saying.
- Yeah.
If you look at these
zippers, these zippers
look like they're painted.
- What is that?
- (laughing)
- We agree on most expensive?
- Yeah.
- Alright, most expensive.
- So what do y'all think about these?
I think the brown was
trying to throw us out,
like, oh, this is an expensive jacket.
I think it's the cheapest jacket.
- I think so, too.
- You think so?
- I think so.
- My bad, bro, you've
got the cheap jacket.
- Yo!
- Yeah.
- I'm gone with it right here.
- Yep.
- Yeah.
- Perfect.
- I'm 100% confident with that one.
- Yeah, me too.
- 100%.
(energetic music)
- So, you guys have made your choice.
This is your final answer.
- Yeah.
- That's got it.
- Okay.
Guys, can you reveal your
actual numbers, please?
- [Interviewer] Oh.
- [All] Oh!
- Damn!
- No way!
- Okay.
- No!
- What?
- Nah!
- No real confidence.
- Nah.
- That's that bargain deal-
- See, it's different.
- Is it wholesale?
- What are you talking about?
- Real fast, real fast, real fast.
What made you think that this one
was the most expensive?
- It's so detailed.
- Yeah.
- The leather looks good to me.
- And it's really gleaming in that light.
- I mean, you guys didn't do that well.
- That was a fluke.
You guys were just tricking us.
- Yeah.
That wasn't real.
- Okay.
(energetic music)
- Here we go.
- Okay, okay.
- Dude's looking sharp.
I mean, you guys might be
taking your job, real quick.
These guys look good, don't they?
- I know.
- Come on, now.
Make your decisions, do your choice.
I'm gonna hop out.
- Okay.
- I'm seeing this, see
these sleeves, over here?
The stitching and stuff
doesn't look good on the end.
Look, see how it's kind of like-
- The one on the far end?
- Yeah.
- Kind of like, fraying.
- I'm leaning towards this
being the most expensive.
Right here.
'Cause if you look at the stitching
on the sleeve right here?
Like how clean that is?
- That's clean.
- Oh, yeah.
- That is really clean.
- This one falls a little bit boxier
than that one.
That one is falling real nice,
like it's on a hanger.
- Right.
I was leaning this being the cheapest
and that being the medium.
- That's what I'm thinking.
That's the medium right there.
- Yeah, let's do that.
So just to clarify,
we've got most expensive
- I'm okay with that.
- Most expensive right here.
We got number two right here.
Least expensive, my man.
- (laughing)
(energetic music)
- So this is what you guys have chosen.
- That's it.
- Yeah.
- Okay.
Everybody please reveal what your
actual prices are.
- Oh!
What?
- There was something about that, man!
Ah!
- You were right, brother, you were right.
- I heard you talking about it.
I heard you say.
- I'm like, yo, there's
something about it.
- Something was messing you up, right?
- Yeah!
(energetic music)
- Go guys.
Here we go.
Yeah.
- (laughing)
- Yeah, son.
- Alright.
- Okay.
- Out the gate.
- I'll just step out, here we go.
You guys do it.
- [Evan] I swear I've seen
them at H & M over there.
- These middle ones?
- The middle ones?
- Yeah.
- I don't know.
- I feel like...
- The quality looks nice, though.
- Okay, you guys are smart,
you didn't get any one
with stitching on it.
- Look at that right there?
- That's enough.
Turn around, turn around.
- (laughing)
- I'm thinking middle is expensive.
- Yeah, I'm thinking
that's the most expensive.
I think these are the least
expensive, right here.
- 'Cause of that fraying.
- That's middle ground right there?
- I don't know what's going on here,
but I wouldn't wear 'em.
- Alright.
Here you go, we got you.
- Yeah, boy.
There you go.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I like this one.
- Me too.
- I'm feeling good.
- I felt really good about this.
- Yeah.
(energetic music)
- Alright, so, final answers, this is it.
- That's it.
- You guys are confident.
Okay.
Can you guys reveal your
real prices, please.
- Wooh!
- Yeah!
- Ho!
Ho!
- Okay, real quick,
real quick, real quick.
Y'all are like, celebrating and you still
only got one right.
- We got one!
- Well we hooked him up that time.
- Okay. Yeah.
- We're just cheering for him.
- That's fair, that's fair, that's fair.
- Look (laughing)
- (laughing)
- Get it boy!
- Hey!
- Has anybody learned, like
a nice lesson here today?
I mean, I feel like personally,
it doesn't take a lot
of money to look good.
- No, I don't think so.
- Nah, not necessarily.
- [Edem] Yeah.
- Thank you fellas so much
for participating today.
You guys were awesome.
Very, you know, good sports
about the whole thing.
Not really good at, you
know, predicting prices
and your job, but.
So obviously you guys only
get paid for being pretty.
That's about it.
- Yeah, pretty much.
- That's cool, that's cool.
- I'll take that.
- Good job.
- Alright, brother, 'appreciate you.
- Hey what's your name, man?
- Hey, we're coming in.
- Yeah, coming in with it.
(techno music)